The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
LARRY VALE: When it
comes to public housing,
current concept of
mixed income housing
really appear very
late in the game
even though public housing
proponents were very focused
on incomes right from the start.
Public housing was not
always for the poorest
and has had a
complex relationship
with ideas about neighborhoods
and neighborhood renewal.
It's really too simplistic
to think of US public housing
as a single failed
experiment and as something
that's now been replaced
by mixed income housing.
I like to think of it
as really a three faced
social experiment.
There's a first phase that
lasted I think from about 1935,
when the program started,
up until 1960 or so.
And it was not about finding the
poorest people from the worst
slums and re-housing them.
It was more about
finding the worst slums
and tearing them down
but not really re-housing
large numbers of the displaced.
Rather, it was a
chance to seek out
large numbers of the barely
poor and to build public housing
communities selectively
from those people.
We don't call them low
income because they probably
had incomes between 50% and
80% of the area of median,
but they're not very low
income and they're not
extremely low income
the way that we
would talk about it today.
But by 1960 or so, and
lasting until 1990 at least,
public housing really
took a different attitude
towards those who
ought to be housed.
By the mid and late
1960s, public housing
was predominantly serving a
very low income constituency.
And by the 1980s, an
extremely low income
constituency, meaning that
it went from 50% or 60%
of the area median into
between 30% and 50%
and then all the way
down to about 15% or 20%
of the median income
by the 1990s or so.
And so that's the phase
of welfare housing
that we think about
as a second phase.
And since 1990 or
so, there's really
been a third face, a
series of initiatives
to return more of public
housing to that first phase
of selectivity to really try
and find again the people who
have less extremely low incomes
to give work preferences
and things like that and to
engage in mixed income housing.
And that's really had
a lot of demolition,
new communities that are
built with different income
structures, and rule structures.
The images that you
see show three phases
using Chicago's Cabrini
Green as an example.
I'm not going to talk
much here about Cabrini,
but when we get to class, it'll
be one of the key case studies,
especially since I've
recently completed a book that
features this place.
But you can see it's a slum.
The blueprint's to build
high rise public housing
that you see in the middle.
And more recently, the
demolition that that
has occurred.
A lot of people have
had different responses
to public housing.
And I think it's worth
looking at three of them.
First is that
journalists and scholars
did have some initial
enthusiasm for the program
and then a lot of controversy,
leading to a second phase
that one might call the design
in decline and fall literature,
where everybody seemed to be
telling a story about failures
of one kind or
another, whether it's
a failure of design or
management or something else.
But since the late '90s,
2000 or so, there's
been a series of
revisionist efforts,
to really rethink the
complexity of public housing
and the values of
what has taken place.
And not see everything
as a complete disaster.
I tend to go really far
back in thinking about it.
And you don't have to do
it entirely to the 1600s
to make sense of this.
But I think it's
important to talk
about ideology and institutional
origins of public housing
and not treat this as simply
something that emerges
in the 1930s out of nowhere.
You may not want to go all
the way back to the 1630s
as I tried to do in my book.
And you certainly don't need to
do that if you come from places
that are very distant
for many Puritans,
but I see a long
continuity in housing
over questions of
really moral judgment.
On the one hand, there's
a reward tradition,
a sense that the government
can help low income
people in ways that reward them
for certain kinds of behaviors.
So in the upper right, you can
see an African American family
taking advantage
of the Homestead
Act in the mid 19th century.
The system that enabled you
to get entire plots of land
if you would promise
to work and live on it
and then it would become
yours after a certain number
of years.
So there's a tradition
that goes with pensions
for veterans and other kinds
of reward that tie housing
to good behavior
and particularly
good working behavior.
And then there's
another tradition
that I might call
the coping tradition.
If you look at the
bottom right, there's
a picture of one of the
[INAUDIBLE] houses in Boston.
This one's from
about 1800, designed
by Charles [INAUDIBLE], the
same guy that did the State
House just a few years earlier.
And it had a wing for men and
a wing for women and a chapel
in between.
And this was the
place where people
went if they really couldn't
afford to live on the town.
They didn't have friends or
family that could support them.
So the state built
a grand edifice
and built a lot of them.
So you have on the one
hand, certain housing
that is given as a reward
for certain behavior
and then another
tradition that's
really about coping with
a set of people that
are not behaving as needed.
By the end of the
19th century, you
get one of my favorite books.
This is called Civilizations
Inferno-- Studies
in the Social Cellar by a man
named Benjamin Orange Flower.
It's the equivalent of the Jacob
Riis book about New York, How
the Other Half Lives.
But this one's about Boston.
And if you look
at it, it's a kind
for the society, the
frontispiece piece of the book
here.
It shows the happy,
wealthy people
in the top dancing
in their town home
while increasingly
levels dire circumstances
of poverty lurking below them.
The immediate next lower level
are the well intentioned men
that are out of work.
The Depression of
1893 was happening.
And they were people for
whom no fault of their own,
they were out of
work, in trouble,
and poor for that reason.
And then there's a
second deserving poor.
The widows and
orphans that you can
see in the third lower level.
And those two were a piece of
the poor of a city like Boston.
But then there was
the social cellar.
They the undeserving poor.
The criminals, the
misbehaving masses tht
couldn't quite be trusted.
And this is the
kind of thing that
made it very
complicated to decide
what is the role of
the government when
it comes to housing.
So when you get
housing authorities,
and here's a picture
of the men who
formed the five person
Boston Housing Authority,
meaning the board of the
authority in the 1940s,
you had a sense of judging
poverty in a different sense.
They wanted to make
sure that the people who
came into public housing were
from that second and third tier
and not from the fourth tier.
And even better,
they wanted to find
people that were ready
to move up into the top.
That were not going to
be employed very long
and were not just deserving
poor, but actually
ready to move onward
into the middle class
and wouldn't need public
housing very long.
So you can see if you look at
a variety of graphic imagery
from all over the country,
the different housing reports
and other city agency
reports were setting
a contrast between
public housing and slums
that was really very important.
The 1930s and '40s
were a time when
people focused on sub
clearance and employment
in the building trades.
And so when you got to
the Housing Act of 1937,
it linked all new low rent
housing to slum clearance.
It mandated an equivalent
elimination agreement.
In other words, public
housing construction
had to be accompanied by
what they called elimination
by demolition or condemnation
or effective closing
or the compulsory
repair and improvement
of unsafe or insanitary
dwelling situated
in the locality or
metropolitan area.
And that that was going to be
substantially equal the number
to the number of newly
constructed dwellings
provided by the project.
So in other words,
public housing
was intended not to compete with
anything in the private sector
because it wasn't going to
make any gains in the low rent
housing stock.
Even if elimination was achieved
by rehabilitation rather than
demolition, the
improved properties
were probably going to
cost a lot more and demand
substantially higher
monthly rentals.
So what this did was to
require or at least encourage
public housing construction
in inner city neighborhoods
rather than the more
affluent peripheral areas.
So it was almost a form
of neighborhood renewal
in the form of
replacement housing
even though many
other neighborhoods
were cleared for
other purposes that
included more private purposes
rather than public ones.
So the Newark
example, the green one
near towards the bottom
right, is a pretty good one.
It's a booklet that shows
the changes between people
in the slum in the
upper left side of it
and the public housing
in the bottom right side.
It's almost a
environmental determinism
from badly behaved people
that need the police
and sit on stoops and don't
do the things they're supposed
to do to the Boy Scouts
and the happy woman
at her sink and
the people playing
in their yard and the sunshine
and the lighter colors
that predominate.
It's almost implying
that the new appliances
are leading to new behavior.
But it's really in practice
more changing of people
rather than changing in them.
At least it's worth
thinking about.
It may be just a
different set of people.
I was struck by that constantly
when I looked at this.
So slum clearance had multiple
forms of justification,
mostly having to do with
issues of crime and health.
Chicago, in this
brochure, depicted itself,
meaning the housing
authority, depicted itself
as having what they
called a dirty backyard.
And it is a very
revealing evidence
for how one thinks about the
relationship between the haves
and the have nots and the sense
that the dirty backyard had
to be cleaned up for the benefit
of those that were valuing it.
The goal was to deal
with what were called
streets of dreariness and
the dangerous people that
lived in them.
It's a sense that these
were a menace to themselves.
So they did charts
like once that compared
the prevalence of
fires and tuberculosis
and violence and juvenile
delinquency between slum areas
and non slum areas.
And there's a
picture on the left
of a family that has a
caption and another place that
makes clear that this is
supposed to be telling you
about the evils of broken
families in the slums
because the husband has run
off and abandoned these women
and girls in that place.
So these attitudes towards
the slums of people and places
to get rid of were
implied largely
to do with things like disease.
The health risks of bad housing
were promoted constantly
in all the brochures
and annual reports
and report-- and other
documents that came out
during the '30s and '40s.
The health risks were paramount.
But there was also a set
of rewards that were still
part of the tradition.
The public housing
had really inherited
from both sides of that reward
and the coping mechanism.
For the most part,
in the '40s, it
was still part of
the reward tradition.
It was used to reward
returning veterans,
like you can see in the
upper left in Los Angeles.
It's an effort to, as
the middle one says,
make juvenile gangsters
take a back seat.
And it's still that
19th century sense
of public housing as a
reward for good behavior
and an accompanying mistrust
for many of the poor.
It really is constant
across the country.
Here's one of my
favorite examples.
In Boston, the Boston
Housing Authority
used dramatic photographs
in their annual report.
This is from the 1940s or so.
And these binary juxtapositions.
Out of the shadows,
into the sun.
It says, if you
can't quite read it,
after they built the first
eight of these projects,
the housing authority wanted
to take stock in the 1940s.
And they said it beheld eight,
clean shining developments
rising fresh to the sun where
once, in dreary dirt filled
dilapidation, slum
dwellings had shambled
in contaminating hopelessness
against a gray and somber sky.
So even the weather was going to
get better from public housing.
But something's
really missing here,
or at least it's
very misleading.
The implication of
the text and the image
is that the children
from the shadowy alleys
are being rescued
by transporting them
into the sunshine and the
openness of public housing.
But I guarantee you
none of those kids
in the left picture ended
up being the happy kids
in the sunshine in the right.
Or at least it's very unlikely.
When I looked at the records,
I saw that of the first four
public housing developments
in Boston, between 50% and 80%
of the people
actually sought entry
into them that were
the ones completed
under the Housing Act of 1937.
But when I actually examined
the lists of tenants
in these places, I found
that only between 2% and 12%
of the projects
had actually gained
a place-- the people gained
a place in the project.
And this is not atypical.
I've seen statistics
for New York that
showed that all the way
up to 1957, only about 18%
of the former residents
of public housing sites
were re housed in the
new public housing.
If the patterns were
consistent around the country
as I think they may have
been, it's more evidence then
that the goals of public
housing were not really centered
on serving the people who
were displaced to create it.
There was just intense
scrutiny about who
was wanted in public housing.
You had to have a head
of the household that
was a US citizen, it
was segregated by race,
it had family sizes that
had to be between two
and nine persons so you
couldn't be a single person.
You couldn't have a large
family or an extended family.
You certainly couldn't be
a gay or lesbian couple.
There were no rooming
houses available,
no living with friends, nobody
without a stable employment
to pay the rent.
It was a very selective effort
to find a public citizen.
And I like this image in the
upper left of the young child
and his picket fence
in the new Norfolk,
Virginia public housing
called a citizen
of Norfolk's Merrimack Park.
They were very pleased
with the people
that they got, whether
it was toddlers or teens.
In the upper right,
the caption says
boy meets girl in a
Brentwood Park home.
All three look nice.
That's the thing
that was going on.
But if you look at the bottom
chart also from Norfolk,
it's an analysis of
who really is intended
to receive public housing.
They said they've
got 47,000 dwellings
and only 17,000 of
them are substandard.
But of those 17,000
that are substandard,
which would seem to
be the good place
to look for public
housing residence,
they found that 4,000 earn
too much for public housing,
meaning they really
weren't all that poor.
But 7,000 earned too little.
In other words,
only 6,000 of 17,000
were the target audience.
What does it really mean to earn
too little for public housing?
It means that they
were targeting
not the lowest of the
incomes, but a near poor group
of people.
And not worrying so much about
the people at the bottom.
They were more interested
in seeing public housing
as a social progression.
In many cases, all the way
from a slum by way of public
housing up to home ownership.
This thing appears repeatedly,
whether in text or in graphics.
The upwardly mobile working
class were intended.
Built in a mixed
income community,
if you want to call it that.
It's just that nobody was very
rich and nobody was very poor.
The assumptions were there
about upward mobility
towards home ownership.
Race is undergirding
all of this, of course.
This is a Miami example of
the situation prevailing
in what they inelegantly called
the central negro district, not
the central business district,
but you can see that off
to just the right of that.
But actually an area that
was seen as a district
defined by race.
And really vilified by race.
If you look at the bottom right
the section of the Coconut
Grove negro area
as they called it,
the blocks are
classified by what
was called the
block median penalty
score, with red and black
being-- red and brown
being the worst cases.
And so you could see
a lot of it was there.
And that had to do with
lending and the things that
were going on and a way of
self-fulfilling a prophecy
of disinvestment in the place.
So this kind of a situation
where white and race were tied
into it were really important.
And there certainly were efforts
going on into the '40s and '50s
to cope with white
racism and deal
with the extent to which
public housing still
needed to be seen as entering
into a segregated city.
The right side is the
Baltimore urban league's effort
to try and downplay the fears
of a changing neighborhood.
But those things were
very much a part of it.
And so public
housing gets built.
And after a short while where
many people were very positive
about it, you enter into
decline and fall literature,
where a lot of the scholarship
from the 1970s and '80s
was just relentlessly
negative about public housing.
Lee Rainwater's book Behind
Ghetto Walls from 1970
about Pruitt-Igoe, written just
before the demolition of it.
Or the book by
Arnold Hirsch, Making
the Second Ghetto in the 1980s.
And then by the 1990s,
Alex Kotlowitz's book,
There Are No Children Here,
about the impossibility
of childhood in the Henry
Horner Homes of Chicago.
Those things were happening.
But what I find
really interesting
is that there have been
revisionist lenses that
really do matter.
Since about 2000,
new ways of looking.
Thinking about what success
has been or could be,
taking the role of tenants
much more seriously.
And also really thinking
about the role of design.
So if we say a little
bit about each of those.
In 2008 and 2009,
I was fascinated
to see two books with almost
diametrically opposed titles
come out.
Brad Hunt wrote about Chicago
with the title Blueprint
for Disaster-- The Unraveling
of Chicago Public Housing.
At almost the same
time, Nick Bloom
is writing a book called Public
Housing That Worked-- New
York in the 20th Century.
Now, one could think it's
just the time period.
The middle volume here, When
Public Housing Was Paradise
is a book about
Chicago in its first 20
years of public housing.
But Bloom's book
says public housing
worked in the 20th century,
meaning all the way up
until pretty recently.
Since 2000, I think there's been
a lot more publicity for New
York and [INAUDIBLE] problems.
And it suggests that some
places, including the city that
has the most public
housing, is very far
from the worst case situation.
But Chicago was probably
the worst for the longest.
Though several other cities
had lawsuits and receiverships
and HUD takeovers and all
sorts of things like that.
In Boston, for instance,
there was a receiver, really
the first of this who took
over in 1980, Harry Spence.
And the court put him in charge
and told him to try and fix
a very broken system.
The Boston Globe
magazine cover here
says that, I think, in some
really interesting ways.
Think about what
you're seeing here.
What is this
suggesting about how
positive change comes about?
Can this man save
public housing?
Is that the right question?
What is it actually asking?
I want to return to this
image when we get to class
and talk about it and
try to deconstruct
it a little bit more.
So think about it.
Think what you're seeing here.
I think that picture
and that sentence
is encoding the whole history
of American housing very neatly
in a single composite image.
So think about what
you're seeing here.
It's not the only picture
like, that strangely.
A decade later, another
housing authority in crisis,
another newspaper,
Sunday Magazine,
is asking a similar question.
Can this man save the CHA,
the Chicago Housing Authority.
This time, the man is the
head of the CHA, Vincent Lane,
a former developer.
And at least he gets to pose
on top of the buildings,
it's Cabrini Green.
I'm not sure that's
an advantage, though.
Is he dwarfed by the challenge
or is he on top of his world?
You can make your own guess.
He didn't last very long
despite making some very highly
publicized interventions
of the mixed income
housing at Lake park place.
The anti-drug sweeps
that brought him national
and international attention.
And by 1995, the CHA was
taken over by HUD from '95
until 1998.
And then they launched the
famous Plan for Transformation
in 2000, which we'll talk
about a bit in class.
So there's a very mixed
record of achievement
from the successes to the
failures to the ambitious plans
to try and turn failure
back into success.
But one of the things
that I find so striking
in recent years is that there's
a latter day revaluation
and revaluing the activism of
the tenants, the residents.
It's really a change
in the scholarship
about public housing.
More of it has become
tenant centered.
It's not just about public
politicians and housing
authority leaders.
But it's about the
coping mechanisms
of tenants who've had to
endure terrible conditions.
It puts people like
Thelma Smith, who's
in the middle picture, a tenant
leader at Boston's Franklin
Field development, it puts them
at the center of the picture
and not shunted to the margins.
Rhonda Williams's
book about Baltimore,
The Politics of Public
Housing, is one.
Roberta Feldman
and Susan Stall's
book, The Dignity of Resistance,
about women tenant activists
at Chicago's Wentworth Gardens.
Sudhir Venkatesh's complex view
of the complexities of gang
culture and politics and
economics at Robert Taylor
Homes in Chicago, American
Project, a project that is now
demolished and we'll
talk about what's
happened to that as well.
My own reclaiming public
housing book about the 50 year
struggles of three
communities in Boston
to try and get past
dire conditions
and return to
desirable communities.
And I think a lot of
people have started
asking the question that's
posed in the title of the book
by Larry Bennett, Janet
Smith, and Patricia Wright,
Where Are Poor People To Live?
It's not so obvious
as public housing
itself has come to change.
The last of the
real changes that I
think is starting to take
place is a more complex view
about the role of design.
More of the thinking
and the writing
has emphasized the
importance of design.
There was always a long
history emphasizing
the negative consequences
and design was always
a key part of that.
The fact that it
was initially built
to emphasize the distinctiveness
of public housing,
not to just be bare and
austere and off putting,
but to appear as a security
and safe and modern alternative
to the wooden fire traps
of the aging slums.
You can see in the middle of
the picture of the Orchard Park
development built in 1942 in
Boston, although the pictures
from 2000 and then a picture
just a few years later of Hope
Six redevelopment
of Orchard Gardens.
Pretty much the same
spot in the place.
But there have been other
aspects to the conversation.
When I see the design centered
revisionism that's taking place
has often taken, again, a
environmental determinist
stance.
There was a book that is little
remembered now by [INAUDIBLE]
and the better known
Christopher Alexander,
called Community and
Privacy, that's 1965.
But it also had the attack on
project centric mentalities
that was much more wildly
and widely influential
by Jane Jacobs in 1961.
And then by 1972, there
was Oscar Newman's work,
Defensible Space-- Crime
Prevention Through Urban Design
that really was
trying to suggest
that it was possible to
use design and urban design
to shape behavior.
It was about crime reduction
and showed early cases
of how public housing
projects could be retrofitted
and redesigned to make them
safer through residence
by encouraging a territoriality.
And it was fascinating to
me in the mid 1990s the way
HUD embraced Oscar Newman's
defensible space ideas
and had him author an
entire manual in the 1990s.
And soon after that, HUD
embraced the new urbanist wing.
You can see a
co-authored publication,
Principles for Inner
City Neighborhood Design
at the left.
And particularly emphasizing
the neo traditional development
side of new urbanism
and was really
trying to rethink the whole
overall image of public housing
developments.
So rather than public housing
being this deliberately
different looking
modernist alternative
to decrepit and ill provisioned
rows of wooden or brick
townhouse that that seem to
signify mid century blight
and slum conditions, the
new urbanist paradigm wanted
to sanitize an
update the reputation
of the pre modern urban models
and make future public housing
look much more like
private sector neighbors.
Not standing implacably, in
part from the [INAUDIBLE],
the colors in the
Orchard Garden look
pretty different
than anything you'd
find in that part
of the neighborhood.
It still stands out, but it
stands out in a different way.
The goal if you take defensible
space and new urbanism
together is a tableau of
middle class Americana, that
normalizes the appearance
of public housing
to a point where it really
could be accepted again
into the fabric of existing,
market friendly neighborhoods.
And that's pretty
necessary if you
want to start thinking
about mixed income.
But it raises a question.
Does Hope Six and HUD's
program with its picket fences
and pastel facades, it's a
new look for public housing
and it's buried within a
larger concept of mixed income
housing, it's managed
by private firms rather
than the public sector,
but is it actually
displacing the poorest again
just like they were displaced
from the slums to build
public housing back
in the '30s and '40s?
There's a book by
Edward Goetz that's
coming out in 2013 called New
Deal Ruins-- Race, Economic
Justice, and Public
Housing Policy.
And I had a chance to look
at an advance copy of it.
And it's an entire book about
public housing demolition.
And it really strongly critiques
the extent of displacement
caused by Hope Six and
suggests that displacement
has been disproportionately
born and has
had a disproportionately
negative impact on African
Americans.
My own book, which is
also due out in 2013,
is called Purging the Poorest--
Public Housing and the Design
Politics of Twice
Cleared Communities.
And despite its
title, it's probably
a little more evenhanded
than the Goetz book,
but it's attempting
to understand
why the leadership
of some cities,
particularly
Atlanta and Chicago,
has been so intent on
introducing mixed income
communities to replace
the public housing
projects of the past.
So really, what I've
wanted to do here
is to frame some of the current
challenges of mixed income
housing.
I hope you're going
to keep in mind some
of these deeper cultural issues
that I've been discussing here.
It's not just public
housing about our attitudes
towards the housing
that is important.
It also matters what we mean
by the public in public housing
and which parts of that
public are expected
to benefit from
housing redevelopment
and what form those
benefits ought to take.
And those are the
things that I hope
you'll think about in
the days up to class
and we'll get a chance to
talk in person very soon.
Thanks.